frankly hi I'm Bruce mcgamer I'm the CEO
of technoServe which is an NGO that
works in four countries in Latin America
and Africa fighting people build good
businesses and given that that's what I
do I was interested to see a quest a
question from a land who dares on
facebook and he wanted to know he said
please tell us what you care about what
future direction you seek and how you
will contribute to improving the state
of the world and given what I just said
about what my organization technoserve
does you know the problem of poverty in
a world of plenty is still I think one
of the bravest sort of moral challenges
of our time and it's something that my
colleagues and I care deeply about and
you know frankly a lot of people are
double set in ironically care about the
same thing and all this becomes a forum
for talking about how you actually take
some of the riches and the resources and
capabilities are people to fill air and
not just use over the context is this as
usual but how you also think about a
broader social agenda and how that I've
got your problems like solving the
problem that is already the body the
problem that is a billion people going
to bed hungry every night the problem is
about four billion people getting by on
less than two dollars a day so that's
what I care deeply about and its really
it's great to be able to come to a place
like this with leaders thinkers people
who with a broader agenda in the world
and engage in conversations that can
want to use the skills talents and
resources that you have to focus a mana
and problem like this one there any
caribou job or you know welcome